life is really just the manifestation of
other people's visions
and i think ultimately you understand
that life is not
a set of constraints that you really
have to optimize under
once you internalize that i think you
understand that really
you can do anything to make a difference
and to really see
through your vision of how things should
be because that's exactly what happened
for other people
my name is alex legal and i'm the ceo
and co-founder of layer one technologies
my company creates a sustainable future
for the internet's growing computing
needs specifically we build
bitcoin mining data centers that help
stabilize energy grids
in the us and globally climate change is
real and
ultimately we have to do something about
it and i think it's about finding
a way that aligns incentives building
these data centers allows us to solve
systemic energy
grid issues and ultimately also
enable the future of sustainable energy
production going forward
the american dream means that what i'm
able to do
is not constrained by how you look how
you how old you are
what you have it's really just what's
your raw horsepower in getting something
done
it's probably a good combination of
arrogance naivety
that leads to entrepreneurship because
you're arrogant enough to think that you
can do it better than others and you're
naive enough to actually try it
you try multiple times different vectors
that you think are worth pursuing and
ultimately you end up stumbling upon
an idea or an opportunity that really
seems
worth for the taking and giving it all
you have once you are in that position
you have no other choice you really have
to give it all you got and have to see
it through and
ultimately if it fails so be it and you
tried your very best and
you still made a difference if you are
successful
well then that's phenomenal and
hopefully you really do create an even
bigger difference than you could have
ever imagined
you